Laughter, tears, and quite possibly the best
third act in any Star Wars movie, all of that's
what I experienced when I watched Gareth Edwards'
Rogue One!
Rogue One's been marketed as a standalone
story within the Star Wars universe, but while
it is tonally different from the other movies,
timing-wise it fits super-snugly before the
events of the first movie in the original
trilogy.
And for fans of the franchise, there are plenty
of cameos and hat tips to previous instalments.
But what about the new cast?
Well, it's a really solid ensemble of actors,
many of whom really make you care for their
characters and give some stand-out turns in
the process.
Unlike Daisy Ridley, who was pretty much an
unknown quantity before The Force Awakens,
you've probably already seen Felicity Jones
in movies such as The Theory of Everything.
So, it's absolutely no surprise that, as the
rebellious Jyn Erso, Jones can play drama
and tender moments to the max, but it's fantastic
to also see her so successfully pull out all
the stops when it comes to some fierce, badass
action.
As K-2SO, a reprogrammed Imperial security
guard, Alan Tudyk gets to play a character
who has no filter but a great line in backchat,
saying whatever pops into his droid head,
which results in a multitude of snark-filled
laugh-out-loud moments that show off Tudyk's
perfect comic timing.
Donnie Yen brings a wonderful sense of calm
and composure to his blind monk character
Chirrut Imwe, and Yen's incredible martial
arts and athletic abilities are also on full
display in some thrilling action scenes.
And I loved the on-screen chemistry Yen has
with Jiang Wen, who plays his soldier friend
Baze Malbus.
Both actors really brought out the beautiful
bond between their two characters to great
effect.
As cargo pilot Bodhi, Riz Ahmed puts in a
fine performance, and as Rebel Intelligence
Officer Cassian, Diego Luna gets to deliver
the hell out of a particularly stirring speech.
While Ben Mendelsohn is suitably unsettling
as the deliciously villainous and ambitious
Director Krennic, and stands out visually
thanks to excellent work in the costume department
by designers David Crossman and Glyn Dillon.
In the role of Jyn Erso's father, Galen, Mads
Mikkelsen brings out his character's strength
and suffering, even during moments of exposition.
After seeing the trailers, I've got to admit
I was a bit worried about Forest Whitaker's
line as outlaw rebel Saw Gerrera, 'save the
rebellion, save the dream', which every time
I saw it at the cinema, screamed Heroes' 'Save
the cheerleader, save the world' to me, and
not in a good way.
So, I was glad to see that it plays out in
a much less cheesy way in the final movie,
and it's actually said in what I felt was
a much more plaintive tone.
See, context is everything!
Oh, and a certain character from the previous
films returns to give you chills!
I really liked the way he's introduced when
we see him fully and I was fine with the amount
he appears in the film.
With so many new characters and locations
to introduce, Rogue One does take its time
to build up a full head of steam and there
is some knotty plotting and certain inelegant
character shifts, which means it's a while
before things get going with the meat of the
movie.
Of course, there's been a lot of talk of long
reshoots and just how much of Chris Weitz's
script was reworked by the Bourne movies'
Tony Gilroy.
How many of those changes fed into some of
the film's issues and how many strengthened
it is difficult to say with absolute certainty.
The film I'm reviewing here is obviously the
one I saw in front of me on the big screen,
and in this Rogue One, director Gareth Edwards
has made a bold film that's darker in tone
than previous Star Wars outings, that does
not shy away from the complexities and violence
of warfare, and that introduces conflicted
characters, many of whom worked their way
right into my affections.
And when the film is at its best, we find
ourselves in the middle of a heist and a war
movie with vibes of Saving Private Ryan meets
The Dirty Dozen, via Black Hawk Down and The
Hurt Locker.
In terms of spectacle, Rogue One is dazzling.
There are so many heart-stopping and stirring
scenes in the movie that brought tears to
my eyes and they build up to an all-encompassing,
incredible crescendo.
And as the film moves into its final phase,
its editors keep niftily cutting between a
variety of characters and locations, ramping
up the tension.
Cinematographer Greig Fraser, who's known
for Zero Dark Thirty, takes us right in to
the middle of the action, getting down and
dirty to full gritty effect, making us feel
every blast and explosion, as he weaves between
obstacles and enemies, just as our heroes
do, amid the dust, smoke and sand.
During action scenes, the camera is fluid
and often handheld, and apparently director
Edwards regularly operated it himself, so
kudos also goes to him for the film's final
look and for also managing to give us both
amazing scale in the movie while still often
keeping action grounded on a more personal
level.
Edwards and cinematographer Fraser also make
great use of the various locations where they
filmed, including the Maldives, for example,
they really bring out the contrast between
beautiful beach-side settings and the full-on
horror of war as things are blown to smithereens
beside sapphire waters.
And perfectly matching the movie's naturalistic
cinematography is Doug Chiang and Neil Lamont's
production design, which brings out the realistically
rough edges of the Star Wars world.
For some superb stunt choreography and some
truly explosive scenes, props also go to stunt
coordinator Rob Inch, who worked on The Force
Awakens and Captain Phillips, and to Oscar-winning
special effects supervisor Neil Corbould,
whose effects you'll have seen in Kingsman
and Black Hawk Down.
And, of course, it couldn't be a Star Wars
movie without some spectacular visual effects,
and for those we have to thank Star Wars veteran
John Knoll, who also came up with the original
idea for Rogue One, as well as Mohen Leo,
who worked on Ant-Man and The Martian.
There are some absolutely stunning moments
set out in space as well as on various planets
and moons, and so many of the scenes of destruction,
which we see from both god's and worm's eye
views, are obviously properly devastating
but also, almost perversely, things of extreme
beauty.
The only place where I'd say the VFX were
slightly off was with the face of one particular
character.
I think they did a good job getting 80% of
the way there in a tough situation, but at
first I did find it distracting, though later
I got used to it, so it didn't spoil the movie
for me.
And, of course, I've gotta give a shout-out
to BAFTA-winning Neal Scanlan and his Creature
Effects team for their work on the movie's
many new cool alien life forms and droids.
As so often happens with the Star Wars movies,
some of their work flies by all too quickly,
so I can't wait to see it on DVD so I can
take a lingering look over some of their new
creations.
With his score for Rogue One, composer Michael
Giacchino has now completed the full Disney
composing package, adding Star Wars to his
scores for Disney animation Zootopia, Disney's
live action Tomorrowland, numerous Pixar films,
and Marvel's Doctor Strange.
And what a great job he's done here too!
And there's even some lovely little moments
blended in at appropriate points from John
Williams' original Star Wars themes, which
always make me feel like a little kid again.
To sum up: Rogue One is full of both stunning
spectacle and genuinely moving moments, and
introduces some engaging new characters given
life by an ensemble of accomplished actors.
Though the film does take a while to rev up
and move through some thorny plot moments,
the pay-off is so worth it that it's entirely
possible that you'll leave the cinema on a
super-high, like I did!
Rogue One is the Star Wars prequel I've been
looking for, and there's so much the film
gets right that, for me, it's up there with
the very best Star Wars movies and its final
act is mind-blowing cinema.
And I'm really looking forward to watching
it again.
So, I'm giving Rogue One 4 and a half out
of 5 Flicks.
Now, what did you think of Rogue One?
Who are your favourite new characters?
And how do you think it compares to the other
Star Wars movies?
Let me know in the comments below!
Coming up soon, I'll have more Rogue One videos
including my easter egg guide to the movie.
So, be sure to subscribe for more movie stuff
like this and don't forget to turn on your
notifications so you get my new videos as
soon as they're ready!
And you also can click or tap here to check
out more of my videos.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!